hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm
michelle cute welcome two reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see star trek into darkness warp
speed ahead reason to see number one the
action there's a lot of [ __ ] action
in this movie there was some action it
starts off with action practically ends
with action it's just non-stop action it
gives you a lot of energy like I didn't
feel like this movie was non-stop action
in the sense of like it's just one long
fight scene but like there are a lot of
really cool different types of fights
and stuff like that and more from me it
was like the urgency was up the whole
movie on a technical level I thought
they improved upon the action especially
the direction from JJ Abrams on it I
felt they could have dialed it back just
a little bit I really love that chase
scene when they first gone to the
Klingon planet have that classic scene
of we're not gonna make it turn their
ship sideways and yeah and they make it
and that's an every good science fiction
come isn't it what we're gonna make
we're not gonna make it with our ship
and they go through a little crack here
now yeah there are two things that are
big right now and it's we're not gonna
make it turn the ship sideways and
really crazy plane crashes yeah yeah
those are the two big action things in
this movie has in a way a crazy big
plane crash oh maybe yeah when the
nation here open the home is your best
tech no one's flying into warp speed
that was crazy yeah nowadays that was
insane that there are a few moments
where I was like oh [ __ ] but that was an
oh [ __ ] moment for me they've kind of
like transformed Star Trek warranted
like the modern era and made it a little
bit less nerdy I love Star Trek I've
been watching Star Trek like since a
little kid with my dad like all of the
shows i guess like it's more like
inflict sci-fi in the intellectual sets
and then in the JJ abrams um like reboot
he's made he's brought that intellectual
aspect of the show
the nerdy aspect but also mix it in with
actions that appeals to more people so
now being into Star Trek kind of mix is
like a cool thing you know that you're
refreshed you know JJ Abrams I think uh
I think some I think he's a better
producer than he is a director and he's
great at what he does and he knows how
to appeal to a mass market so I can see
if some track D fans are a little like
down at the end of the day you know they
make summer movies like this to appeal
to a much larger audience i mean the
before the rebooted Star Trek there was
Star Trek nemesis which like made no
[ __ ] money and now they're doing this
which is like a global box office hit so
it's like which one are they gonna do
more satisfying trying to satisfy the
few or trying to satisfy the majority
I've heard it said that especially with
the Star Trek movies they're really
uneven in their track record where it's
like some really good others are really
not good and that was like after so much
time they were like why don't we just
try again like why don't we just do
something different you know being a
nerd is like cool now yeah that's like
what me 21 Jump Street so funny was like
yeah the nerds are like this [ __ ] now
like if you know a ton about comic books
or television shows and movies head they
tend to be the cool ones now it is a
hard demographic to satisfy reason to
see number two Benedict Cumberbatch
there any cucumbers amazing in this
movie man yeah sure he's a scene stealer
for sure he has this incredible ability
to be threatening same time has moments
where you get this guy like you
sympathize for him well yes you think
you do I don't know he's a great
manipulator or fees and we always kind
of just telling the truth a lot of the
time at least his version of the truth
but that's what they say it's like what
makes a great villain is that they
believe what they're doing is yeah the
thing to do it's like they believe
they're right they don't know that
they're they don't think of themselves
as evil you know I liked how it wasn't
just good guy bad guy there was
something about him where I I totally
got where this guy was coming from I
could I can understand his reason for
vengeance and whatnot like then it's
cool how in ways he can influence Kurt
in some aspects the movie maneuvers are
heroes into this place where you don't
know who to trust and part of that
is because he's so compelling so you're
like should we trust this guy or is he
messin with us but I don't know he seems
like I don't know like you believe that
he is intellectual like you told I did
not doubt that he liked is smart he
played I think he played that aspect of
the character really well i think he was
menacing i think he was threatening and
he played that really well and I think
sometimes it can be difficult to show
both sides you know cuz you can get
someone who's way too threatening or
someone who's way too like intellectual
he manages to bring those two aspects
together very well his voice is very his
voice is deeper than you think it would
be looking at his face yeah and like the
first thing I thought when you started
talking was I didn't realize how deep
Benedict Cumberbatch's voices a lot of
fans of or people who even just saw Star
Trek to the wrath of Colin we're getting
kind of upset with the fact of how he's
nothing like Khan and from the original
owes you know yeah cuz like I know that
Khan was played by like I can't I don't
know these okay yes a Mexican guy played
on hand because Khan was originally on
an episode of Star Trek and then they
made a movie with con me the the
ultimate villain of the whole Star Trek
series and some people are finding
insulting because star trek to is is
some people consider that the best one
out of all the Star Trek movies I
personally was not upset because I don't
I didn't know [ __ ] about Khan beforehand
so i was able to accept what the
filmmakers were going for in its own
merits I thought it was [ __ ]
brilliant just the entire court trail of
it all he's a supervillain he's not just
intellectual badass he's also [ __ ]
has super strength that is why I did not
like the way he was taken down at the
end I thought it was kind of a cop-out
just okay yeah he gets in a fight
another day and by it I felt he deserved
more of a yeah there could have been
more of a half when they have the whole
leg how did you defeat him yeah there
should it's like how did you do there
should have been a much bigger defeat
but it could have been much more of a
heroic triumphant moment yes that's the
brill
way of how they got it you're watching
it going how do they take this guy down
yeah how will they defeat him and then
he loses to a fistfight in a stun gun it
sounded like 10 it's not a lot but I I
thought would they could have been more
creative and had a bigger payoff reason
is see number three Captain Kirk I love
this actor I know I haven't I don't know
any other movies have seen or anything
but I really do like Chris I I love
Chris Pine a lot I think he's [ __ ]
awesome he's hot he's charming as ever
he's one of those guys that you see is
like yep he's a good looking
[ __ ] yeah a second yeah he has
okay with this guy he knows how to
command the screen too i mean i think
when it came to his scenes with a
Benedict cucumber he really allowed him
to take over the scene he seems like a
leading actor who's not afraid to show
the screen at all yeah he knows how to
really lead a cast very well hey
cooperating he's funny too he's really
funny he's funny but I also really just
like what they did with his character
he's sort of going off wild-eyed you
know because it's all it's all comes
from a very heated situation when Pike
dies and all that stuff and they're like
we're going for revenge and like he's
constantly conflicted and meeting
resistance and then after a while it is
like I just love that that whole scene
kind of sums it up where he's like I
don't know what I'm supposed to do that
all I know is what I can do and I felt
like he that was the essence of his
performance they really make Captain
Kirk like the theme of the movie
whatever Kirk has to go through yeah you
know that whole life you don't know how
to follow the rules you know you're a
rebel and we don't like rebels but you
know of course there's always something
the rebel that makes him the exception
do you know it's like that the moment
you're talking about it yeah because a
lot of this is about following your gut
following your emotion or do you follow
logic which one do you follow the rules
you go against the rules and they really
make Curt that central theme of all of
that he's a perfect middleman for
because you know Spock is at a really
low central parts of this movie and
Benedict cucumbers a real essential
parts of this movie so when you have him
as the guy to really control that theme
it makes for a perfect executed theme
yeah Oh reason to see number four Spock
dude man Zachary Quinto they even a lot
more to do in this one yeah it's like
they let him run the show at one point
yeah yeah yeah they really played up the
Spock Kirk relationship oh yeah and also
they brought a little more into Spock as
a character and stuff like that they
bought it they brought like a bromance
into it but it was like it was like a
trouble breathing it's like trying to
work through it you know try to figure
out where that spark is again yeah
exactly exactly some people are getting
upset about how much they're exploring
his human side which I kind of get
because what makes what made Spock so
cool was he's half Vulcan and so you get
to explore the Vulcan side because
because that's what you want to see cuz
he's a Vulcan we got to explore the bulk
inside for how many [ __ ] years now
it's it let's explore his human side and
I'm totally on board for that because
it's such a repressed sign of him it's
his most fascinating side of my opinion
because his Vulcan side always shines
it's it's constantly there he's way more
bulky than he is human way because most
of the time he behaves like a Vulcan
yeah he believes himself to mainly be
Vulcan he doesn't really acknowledge his
human side to begin with so when you
explore his human side and I did like
how they blinked it back to the first
one like hey my planet was blown up and
that's why the tatra my emotions yeah
cuz you don't want to argue with him on
it like I get it have you lost a planet
yeah all right chillum idolized it all
of mine and our whole world I think I've
been idled to this so like a town was
destroyed my planet is obliterated you
guys lost your archives I lost my entire
world yeah what do you know about pain
exactly this is any day it's still
making the right choices in its it's
cool because Kirk has to learn how to
play by the rules more understand logic
more man Spock has to understand emotion
more and understand emotional decision
making way more so that moment that you
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
debate about that one [ __ ] scene when
Kirk dies and they switch the roles and
spot becomes that becomes a hero at that
point on if people are they
about that because it was you know that
scene from parodied a lot it was such a
famous signature moment back then in it
I thought it was effective as ever I I'm
way Yoko knows I thought I was pretty
[ __ ] cool to be honest yeah and to
see the sea and we really get in touch
with him I felt that drug when he's
going after when he's going after Khan
we know you feel that emotional sense of
like yeah go go get him don't give ya
find him on him down run through the
city of that that was all great because
you really feel for Spock at that moment
you really feel that sense of revenge
coming in when his chemistry with Kirk
isn't fantastic yeah they have really
good chemistry I just love the way they
bounce off each other and their dialogue
is just great I just I think that they
built upon that from the first way
because there has pretty good chemistry
in the first movie but in this one you
really get to see it it's very realistic
you know if you haven't I guess for guys
you know that's like your that's your
bro don't throw really watch it was nice
warm and fuzzy they're the perfect
balance because Kirk is all emotional
and Spock is all logical and to have
that the one-two combo it's just a
feather yeah it's perfect oh god is
great i like this movie a lot more than
i thought it even just strip it down to
the most simple thing I just like the
way he plays that character I just like
to watch what Zachary Quintos doing yeah
he's a really good actor I mean I didn't
see heroes but I know like my parents
watch heroes and I remember them saying
oh yeah you know that guy who played
Spock he's so good in heroes too just
like he was in Star Trek and nice to see
that he's consistent with that way to
see number five the humor something that
I really liked about this movie is that
they maintain that humor that was in the
first one it was such a nice thing to
see because that's what made the first
Star Trek so like whimsical and
uplifting and I like that they kept that
I didn't find it as funny as the first
it wasn't you're absolutely yeah I
thought it's called star chick in a
darkness and I do think he goes in a
much darker terrain than it does then
the first one did and so I think that's
why the humor wasn't as present the
doctor they don't really give
then even that much drama to do but he
had some great one liners too yeah love
other than the metaphors in a drink I
think the third Star Trek is gonna be
called star trek into light heartedness
but as it stands there was a lot of
stuff I was chuckling at it there was a
lot of stuff that I was like smiling
about because I was just having a good
time and the characters you know say
what you will about like depth and
whatnot but like all the characters had
personality and they were all I don't
just they were just all making me laugh
at some point you know Scotty's really
fun and bones is fun and you know
Captain Kirk's got his sort of you know
Captain Kirk II sarcastic ness and even
just situational nice even Spock is
funny yeah everybody gets their moment
it's great to have that sense of humor
in there where it doesn't feel like
they're turning this into a comedy where
the humor is obviously coming from the
character's personality brief is e
number six visual effects that's why the
the the one thing I think everyone's
gonna agree on with this phone yeah they
are fantastic I saw this on imax 3d and
they shot 30 minutes of this is actual
IMAX cameras and for those for those of
you who don't know why that's
exceptional who is because most movies
at play on imax screens it only takes it
like the center of the screen this one
takes up the whole [ __ ] screen and it
has the best quality you'll ever see it
was beautiful look at but I can probably
guarantee that even if it wasn't our max
it would still look amazing I did not
see it on imax and it still looked
amazing oh there you go and it was just
beautiful it was such a treat to us and
the great thing is like they throw you
into a world and well several worlds
what the heck they're into a certain
type of universe the visual effects
don't detract from keeping up with the
story and keeping up with everything is
a lot of times you get movies this movie
has like visual effects and almost every
[ __ ] shot which is fine for this film
though I it works out perfectly for this
particular movie it keeps you even more
pulled in and it's consistently
impressive and very real a lot of the
time too yeah I mean is it's all the
visual effects all seem to be in places
where
they're necessary and then there's your
makeup effects and stuff elsewhere and
real creature effects and animatronics
but you know the visual effects all seem
to go where they're needed and they're
all really good I mean yeah reason to
see number seven production design love
like just the landscape of everything to
see attention to detail and almost every
single shot and whenever they go through
like Starfleet or just the Caesar and
you know like you get all the London and
daddy whatever whatever whatever looks
really doing and like San Francisco and
what every year there's anything just
Nibiru like the planets there on or
whenever they go through Starfleet and
you see all this crazy detail in the
background of all these different types
of ships and what not even of things
like you know technology like their guns
and torpedoes all that stuff it's really
cool then the costumes are awesome like
and the makeup all of it was great i
love the look of the new Klingons it's
got a flare it you know it looks like
it's got our lens flare reason to see
number 8 Scotty they gave him more to do
and he delivered on what they gave him
to do well and the thing about Simon
Pegg that I love you know he's really
funny but also he can play really
dramatic moments and he could be very
heartfelt and they utilize all of his a
lot of different skill even in my Shaun
of the Dead or hot fuzz he he knows how
to bring that right amount of balance so
that way it's believable it out that way
it's not like you're just watching a
comedian on screen you're watching
somebody who's a human being who happens
to be really funny they really showed
why he is an essential part to the crew
yeah definitely reason is see number
nine cinematography they have some crazy
angles in there like some great oh yeah
you know there's some crazy moments
where although just be like zooming in
but then turning into a Dutch angle and
while they're serving in it so sometimes
I thought the camera was a little over
the place was kind of hard for me to
tell what's going on for the most part
yeah there's some incredible
cinematography in here I didn't ever
think there was a moment where I
couldn't understand what was going on
visually you know I really liked just a
composition of the shots though the flow
of everything the look every shot is
like an awesome thing
yeah it's like even if they're just in
the hull of a ship it's like but this is
really cool looking yeah because this
have a very signature look to it reason
to see number 10 the music yes and I
found myself thinking part way through
this movie is like this is really cool
score so there's a lot of cool sounds
and dynamics and stuff like that I love
the way how we do our show because we
really break it down you know into like
so many different categories what makes
a makes a movie this works so well is
you take all these different categories
and you turn them into like synergy and
music is such an essential part but we
don't really look at all these other
things and music is what helps really
omit that emotion to the audience and
anything especially what you're seeing
just a series of images in front of you
and music helps make all that a much
more much more smooth much more fluid
yeah and the music and this really does
help amplify the experience well its got
like a throwback equality at times you
know it's it's just really interesting
to listen to and especially that
combined with just the other sound
effect yeah like it really makes the
experience he of complete reason not to
see number one rushed ending yes so when
they take out benedict and it all ends
right there it just ends like there
there's it just cuts to black and then
everything's resolved everything's okay
yeah it is a feels a little bit as that
that would be my one complain about this
movie if anything is like and it didn't
it didn't like DeRay litter or bug me
that much but it was kind of like oh
we're at the height of momentum yeah
that's kind of like oh yeah okay so
Kirk's getting better are we gonna go
get Benedict together or something are
we gonna go beat the [ __ ] out you must
have him write like peasant from there
it's like then things are wrapping up
and it was it took me a second to get
back with it cuz I was like yeah maybe
because of how it ended I couldn't even
feel that heroic speech that Kirk was
giving to the whole like Academy at the
end of it yeah I gotta play this
patriotic music and everything but I was
so like thrown off guard by how
everything you just sort of went Bam Bam
Bam
even I think like a third act was kind
of just like not not as much as that one
pretty like any but just the third act
felt a little bit rushed to me because
it was just bombarded with so much
danger danger danger action actually
just nothing like a whole bunch of chaos
and then what an end sigh yep all of its
ok guys don't worry we cut to black and
we didn't show you the resolution but
it's resolved I feel like climax and
then it's like right down here like you
don't step down gradually to the enemy
it's like steep slope ends and then
they're kind of like wait what what the
heck just happened like I say it doesn't
derail the movie for me that in that way
but it is a bit because I think the
third act is fine that was the only time
where I start to feel like it gets a bit
rushed and it's it's not even like you
need to see that because you know
exactly what they're gonna do like it's
not like you're remiss for the
information but when they don't give you
that conquering moment though of yes we
are but you should accomplish you know
yea rather than yeah they just it's like
they have like the big problem and then
they have the resolution but what about
that mid middle section of
accomplishment that they show you
breezes Nazi number two and I just plot
points the one plot point that really
just stands out to me was how like the
leader star flee the established like
he's a bad corrupt guy he's got some
evil intent going on but they don't seem
to acknowledge that amongst Starfleet
and that doesn't really seem to bother
anybody about hey like the top of the
ladder there's actually a lot of
corruption going on yes is there any
other corruption going on is there
something else that's wrong they kind of
just go no we took them out so
everything's okay there is a little bit
and it ties back into the ending it is a
little bit like we could have spent ten
extra minutes back at home go over what
we just went through and be like okay so
now we know that this guy wasn't so good
and now we know that you guys did a good
job and this is what happened to con
like split decision number one
ineffective drama okay like I noticed
had a ton of great things about this
phone but honestly from watching it I
just remember not being as pulled in as
I felt I should have been I was find
myself getting distracted by a lot of
things
and just never really feeling the human
complexity of it all going on I couldn't
feel a lot of the drama going on it just
seems to be more about adventure and the
thrills rather than actually having more
of a captivating story being told cos
that's what I love so much about the
first Star Trek was the drama was really
[ __ ] fell just the first five minutes
people were like bawling their eyes out
because chris hemsworth died and in this
one none of the drama really got to me
like that especially they even that
moment where Kurt dies just couldn't
just could not buy it I felt like the
drop like I felt like the outline and
the idea of the drama was really good I
just felt the emotional impact wasn't
there I don't know man I got infected by
pretty much everything in this movie I
thought they did a good job I mean I was
invested in I was with it i bought the
Jeopardy i bought the peril even even
that moment you were talking about you
know i was pulled in enough that i
wasn't thinking about or they're gonna
wake him up like you know it's like see
it made sense to me but honestly the
twist where Kirk guys I saw it coming I
saw the way he revived coming I saw that
from like as soon as he entered the
little radioactive volt I was like oh
he's gonna die and then [ __ ] revive him
with um cond blood so when he actually
died I was not like tripping I don't
really die what's gonna happen is my
gosh spent so much time on it ya like it
didn't pack because I recall coming and
obviously you know he's not gonna die
he's he's the main character and who
knows they could switch to Picard boom
yeah Vin Diesel
this argument is going to sound weird
because I get exactly what you're sayin
with that is like if you see something
coming then why play it out but I kind
of liked it they let the Kirk death
scene play out because I mean for as
much as that's a plot point it's also
about the two of them though it's about
Kirk and Spock in that moment and then
the crew you know so I didn't mind that
they loved that plow is happy to let
that play up because that gave me the
emotional impact of that scene you might
just completely change my whole opinion
on that scene because now that I look
back on it you're absolutely right
because it is about their growth in that
particular moment it's not so much about
hey Kirk's dying look how seven yes I'm
it's not about shrinking the audience
about their good Wow yeah really talking
about that a moment because because it
is about how Curt like pretty much
sacrifice himself like you know like
when Benedict is like what would you do
for your crew yeah and so he shows he's
willing to sacrifice his life to save
their asses and at that point is when
smogs like [ __ ] it I'm in touch with all
my emotions that you know yeah it's the
culmination of everything that Kirk has
been told up into this point and also
everything he's sort of come to be he is
still that guy who like like we said
before is only doing what he knows he
can do not what he thinks he should do
it's like he's coming full circle as a
captain but also still keeping true to
that vibe of like I only know what I can
do and you know I bought that seemed
really well and ultimately it is about
him and Spock in that moment together I
think my just my biggest issue with
honestly as I didn't feel I want to feel
that at the end up victorious like yeah
like they gone and like they were they
like achieved it and I wanted to feel
that like that emotional like oh no like
despair and I didn't feel that and I
guess that's where I kind of feel
disappointed because we compared to the
first one like I did definitely felt
like that oh no and I definitely felt
that like yes they know they succeeded
and I didn't get that this time like I
had moments I was like oh yes for most
of it I felt like everything's gonna be
okay everything's gonna and
that kept being convinced they were
gonna start killing characters
especially when we like Chekhov go put
on a red shirt I was like no don't go
put on a red shirt check off no like and
then when when the bones gets his arm
continent thing and then you know they
bring Scotty bag and Scotty's on the
mothership I kept thinking like oh [ __ ]
bad things we even happen to good
characters like that for me was it was
not for me I felt the writing I guess so
much of like how do we make this more
dangerous because I was so we're of them
trying to throw in danger I never felt
like the danger would ever fully meet
the potential of like the worried that
you were experiencing the fear that you
were experiencing like that moment when
his hands caught I was like it's gonna
be okay like every like any moment I was
like it's gonna be okay everything's
gonna be alright yeah I can see why you
would feel I don't know exactly why I
was so pulled into this particular movie
but it was you know the way it sounded
going it was gonna be like oh there's
like ten problems at once and it just
seemed like one big problem they kept
escalating like it would I say I did
feel like it was like the 10 big
problems at once tyfa that's what i
thought the third act was a little bit
chaotic is it was like then there's a
lot of things going wrong it makes sense
but it felt a little too much uh i guess
the reason for the ineffective drama
would have to be because of our second
split decision oh dang split decision
number two lacks character exploration
this was my biggest disappointment I
felt like we didn't get to explore all
of the characters while in the first one
we got a sense of each and every one of
the characters yeah you really like them
you got to know them and you're like all
their an ensemble they're great Baker
Bailey work together so great and this
one there was a lot of uneven screen
time a lot of uneven attention to each
of them and that kind of fun yeah for me
this film seemed way more about just the
adventure and just the escalating
thrills and the escalating danger but
part of what made part 1 so effective to
me was each character has their own
unique personality and they really each
character felt very three-dimensional
this one's heart no I don't like you
I felt like it was more caricatures of
everyone rather than them all feeling
like a true ensemble again it didn't
feel like we're hanging out with these
guys again are we getting to explore
them more it was like yeah we already
established they were in the first one
now just make it about the adventure and
the only ones i felt i could really go
to explore what Kirk and Spock you don't
really get to get the full grasp of
everyone in the full sense of fun and
dynamics of this whole cast coming
together as I felt with the first one I
felt like they kind of pushed all that
to the side like with the doctor they're
like this is making a funny guy yeah
that was it is a funny guy where is in
part one he was he was really a much
more of a not a number two in the way
how Spock was but a much more close with
her even with Sulu he had more unique
character traits to explore in the first
one and Scotty didn't get as much screen
time but in they so they gave him or to
Scotty but I just with the whole cast in
general there was just something there
that was missing which didn't make the
drama as effective to me I'm because I
didn't I felt like if you didn't see the
first one you probably won't give two
shits yeah why do we do cuz I you see
them as on the ship and it's like oh soo
do this Oh her your chance at okay cool
yeah rushing it's like okay like I don't
give a [ __ ] about that was everyone
doing their job doing their adventure
but not really getting to explore these
guys yeah okay so everything you guys
said but the opposite of that experience
I had with this was like I don't know I
really liked him as an ensemble I
thought everybody had several moments
where I was like oh yeah you know bones
Oh check out all you know Scotty my man
that was the issue it was moment oh no
man screams no I'm same time I'm saying
that these moments come and go but they
don't stay there resonating throughout
my resident for me like I always thought
of them as an ensemble even though it
does yet it is more about the adventure
than getting janelly characters I'll
give you that which isn't a problem for
me because I feel like we got to know
that I'm and now we know them and things
are gonna change in their dynamics but
you know I liked what they gave me I
thought it was a great ensemble I
thought everybody you don't have just as
much personality I thought everyone was
important and you know I really liked
all the characters this time around look
in the first one you explore the
characters and have great adventure you
have great drama they could have done
that in this second movie and they did
it and that was disappointing is because
it could they could have done it and
they did it this one they did everything
Sarge egg one has but they cut back
significantly on character I am I
disagree with you I don't know what else
to say hey like I'm is you're not you're
not agreeing with us and that's what's
getting really bad shape of a character
study like you know that's why people
love it Star Trek because it's just
you're supposed to be there will be
blood like women's what makes Star Wars
stand like sarwar stand out is the
characters who make Star Trek so unique
isn't character it's not just about
adventure and space it's now about
America it doesn't have to be this great
character study the first one is in this
huge character study either but at the
end of the day they offer they all fell
way more three-dimensional than they did
in this one okay well let me just say
this in the first movie and all the star
trek series the crew there an ensemble
they interact together it's not just oh
this dude toxic Kirk and this dude toxic
earth and this dude talk to Kurt
enlisted talk to Kurt but Delta piglet
watch it is about everyone talking to
each other and interacting with each
other in this movie it was always okay
Spock and Kirk and then Scotty incurred
and then someone's dealt with Kirk and
then someone else with Kirk and so miles
of Kurt Ryan's consensus there are
strong enough reasons to see star trek
into darkness there are strong enough
reasons to see star trek into darkness
the stuff that I didn't really like
about it i I really don't agree with
strongly which kind of makes me go it
was a disappointment but when I look
back on it I liked it a lot more than
when I first watched it series consensus
there are a lot of strong reasons to go
see star trek into darkness there are a
lot of strong reasons to go
star trek into darkness yeah man I had a
great time with this movie I had a blast
there are a few you know hiccups here
and there but nothing that really
detracted that much for me Michelle's
consensus there are a lot of good
reasons to see star trek into darkness
there are a lot of good visas to see
star trek into darkness despite the
things that I was disappointed about the
movie all in all I really enjoyed it I
had a great time watching it and I would
definitely recommend it to other people
and I would watch it again alright guys
thanks for checking out our show why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box and tell us what is your favorite
Star Trek movie just tell us which one
you like if you saw this you star trek
tell us what you thought about it did
you love it you hate it leaving go into
some of the spoilers and piss off the
other people who haven't seen the movie
yet who read rate comment oh and if you
want to see more episodes of reasons to
see we got a little link right down here
so once you go ahead and click it and if
you want to see my straight to the point
review of star trek into darkness if you
want to know what the difference is well
you just got to click that link right
here and if you want to get updated
every time a new review or a video is
out go ahead click on Michelle people
click that button subscribe we want you
to subscribe so you can continue hang
out with us every week yeah punch it
yeah warp speed to the subscribe button
I could tell you really wanted to say
that would you ever have sex with
someone who had Vulcan yours by Will
Smith like real naughty got his Vulcan
here six he has satellite years it's a
really cool scene when Boba Fett shows
up in the movie you cross over what if
that ends up happening because JJ is
directing oh no that would be cool
movies yeah I would love to see that
that'd be tight i don't i would love to
see like Kurt and Luke's Luke Skywalker
there isn't even earth in Star Wars and
then you just could be across the
universe it's in the middle earth step
ahead JJ Abrams will make Battlestar
Galactica the movie and we're going to
cross them all over and then you know
what
you